now if I'm trying to find what you two
is right I will be given my probability
density function I'll be given
boundaries like what's your shortest
person what's your tallest person and
then I can use either of these integrals
to then work out
q2 can I give you an example yeah I need
sorry bear with me we're gonna do I had
to make up an example cuz I couldn't
find I couldn't find a good one okay so
I'm gonna give you guys a probability
density function like so and what we're
going to do is find the median okay
that's what we're going to try and find
so here is our function and we want to
try and find Q okay we're gonna try and
find the median okay how am I gonna do
this alright now think about what this
means by the way um you don't have to do
this and you might feel like oh this is
a bit time-consuming to do it but I'm
just going to give you a rough sketch of
what this looks like and encourage you
to follow along with me right if I were
to think about what is the shape of this
probability density function 1 minus X
onto um what is this graph is it a
parabola is it a log what is it
it's just linear is it it's just a
straight line what can you tell me about
this straight line it cuts through it
wait cuts through it huh at x equals 1/2
or wire goes on where's-where's a cut ah
good so and this is actually my
y-intercept here right
Mike was once I'm just gonna put one in
there right and then yeah the gradient
is what it's it's negative is that steep
is it
is it shallow what is it it's it's
downwards and the gradients are 1/2
right so it's pretty shallow so would
your draw with me this is what I'm
getting right do you agree with that
what is this point over here by the way
this end point here what is it what is
the x-intercept yes - isn't it very good
ok so the x-intercept is 2 now look at
this this is just a triangle yeah it has
a height of
it has a base of two so what's its area
base times height on two that's equal to
one right it had better equal to one
because what is this thing supposed to
represent one it's a probability density
function are you so far so good okay so
what I'm trying to find is there's some
value in here q2 that will break this
this triangle has a total area of one
I'm trying to find the value that breaks
it into fifty-fifty do you agree I'm
just going to kind of eyeball that like
it can't be it halfway
do you agree because like then this
train will clearly be smaller than this
so I think it has to be a little bit
this way I don't know what exact value
but he's been I think it's somewhere
around there and here's the thing right
like in terms of what shapes I can cut
this into all I've got is vertical lines
that I can use right so this this value
here is going to have to of course want
to go up and then divide into two
sections right like you're tall half the
cost in your shorter car for whichever
my big this is what we try to find is
that okay now I've got two tools in my
toolbox for finding the median an
integral from my lower boundary to the
median and an integral from the median
to the upper boundary in this situation
have a look at what my boundaries are
which do you think is easier to work
with lower bound or your upper boundary
the lower boundary I agree with serene
why is the lower boundary an easier one
to use in this case it's a triangle not
a trapezium that is true have a think
about the values that have given us that
triangle they're shiny what are you
seeing the lower boundary is zero see
that
I love integrating and substituting 0 in
because a lot of the time it just my
terms just disappear so it's just easier
working for me I will leave it for you
to have a go you can you'll still get
the same answer if you try the other one
you'll just have a bit more work to do
okay so let's try this out shall we I am
going to now form that integral over
there for this particular function so
I'm going to say since Q 2 is the median
here's me introducing what my notation
is right then integral from the lower
boundary which we just established it is
tell me out guys lower boundary is zero
okay up to so I'm going from zero all
the way over to my median cute shoe in
this case I don't know what its value is
okay it's going to be of this function
this is my probability density function
with respect to X I know what this
should equal to it should give me half
of the people or half of the scores I
don't even know what this poverty
density function represents so it's
gonna equal 1/2 that makes sense
so now I've set up the the goals I need
to integrate now yes so can you help me
work out what the primitive should be
very nice there we go
nailed it one turns into X increase my
power and divide by that new power
everything looks good I go from naught
to this cue to business and then that
equal to 1/2 so far so good ok I've got
I've got my integration already done so
now I'm going to substitute in my two
boundaries yeah so here comes my upper
boundary it's gonna be a q2 minus q2
squared on 4 it's not just a straight
substitution I'm like I don't know what
this q2 is but I will work out what it
is in a second and then I subtract my
lower boundary
aha this is why we chose it right 0
minus 0 squared over 4 it's just 0
equals 1/2 so far so good it looks a bit
weird because but we can we can work
with this yeah ok so yeah I've got
fractions here that I want to deal with
right now the easiest way that I think
of to do with fractions is to multiply
everything left and right hand side by
some constant that will get rid of all
the fractions in one here what's the
smallest number I can choose if I
multiply by 2 or get rid this fraction
but I don't go into this one will I like
it'll still be Q squared - 2 squared on
- so I should multiply by 4 right and
you would choose whatever number based
on what terms you have here if I
multiply 3 by 4 I get 4 Q 2 - what
q2 squared median squared equals what on
the right hand side pink what do I
multiply everything by I got four on two
which is which is two fantastic okay now
this is a bit weird and awkward this is
a quadratic though and I know how to
deal with quadratics there could be
quadratics an X or T or you or in this
case the median okay so I'm what am I
gonna do what I'm gonna try to get
everything on one side is that okay that
seems like a usual tactic that I use I
will add q2 squared median squared I'll
subtract for lots of the median and then
there's that pasta - that was hanging
around there in the beginning have a
look at this hmm what's this thing equal
to how do I solve this quadratic can I
factorize it hmm
I'm searching for a pair of numbers it
adds to negative 4 multiply is 2 to the
only whole numbers I know that multiply
to 2 are 1 and 2 right okay so stop for
a second I've got a bunch of different
ways to handle quadratics right I tried
to factorize I know about you but no
numbers are leaping to my head so then
what do I do instead of factorizing well
I can't back rise you can complete
square or we can automate that process
by doing there for the quadratic formula
all right now I know you're like oh
really I didn't want to do that okay but
I
I don't know how so let's give this a go
come on help me out guys all right Shh
stay with me we can work this out like
the quadratic formula I know we haven't
done it for a while but we actually got
pretty good at it right so I'm gonna say
I'm gonna start over here cuz I'm gonna
need more work right q2 equals minus B
which in this case what is B look
carefully what's minus B B is B is
negative 4 right so minus negative 4 is
4 do you agree with that
there's minus B plus or minus the square
root of B squared which in this case is
16 because that's negative 4 squared
take away 4ac
what's a C in this case 1 times 2 right
so that's that's a 2 all divided by 2a
which in this case is just 2 ok stay
with me stay we think we can do this ok
what comes in underneath the square root
zone it's 16 minus 8 which is 8 all on
two I can go one better than this
there's a square number I can pull out
of this right what's the biggest square
you can factorize out of that the
biggest square number I can pull out is
4 so I'm gonna pull out square root of 4
what you guys all know is 2 so I'm
getting this on 2 and now I've got a
common denominator on the top of the
bottom namely 2 so what happens when I
divide through oh yeah sure go ahead
yeahbsolutely can so let's factorize the
top by 2 that leaves me with 1 on the
top 2 plus or minus root careful careful
that's the 2 we factorize out so it's
still a root 2 that's left is that okay
that's divided by 2 cancel cancel now I
have answers now hold on a second I got
two answers because I got a quadratic
right that's kind of you know fair
enough
but but I'm not supposed to have two
medians right like that's the thing I'm
trying to work out so hopefully I can
reason my way through showing that one
of these values is no good have a think
you've got all the information on the
board one of these doesn't work but
which one is it
cut can't have a - like there's this guy
and then there's this guy what are you
on hold on one at a time Michonne what
are you thinking ah three point four is
outside of our domain which of course it
should be because you're like wait a
second after to this probability density
function it just borrows into the ground
you're not allowed to do that right and
that's why the domain restriction was
there so even though like we're so used
to say our negatives get rid of those
guys right
in fact the negative is the one that
works it's the positive that goes
outside the domain of our probability
density function are you with me okay so
how do I capture that right I'm gonna
say but but I have a restriction on X
right I had it from the first line of my
question right therefore X can't
possibly be 2 plus root 2 so therefore
it has to be the other one Q 2 must
equal 2 minus root 2
now root 2 is about 1.4 so if you do 2
minus that you're gonna get a something
like point 6 you go ahead and get the
actual value does that match you that
intuition of what we expected
it's Mountie all right